There is an enigmatic and
powerful mathematical operation
at work inside everything from
computer graphics
and neural networks, to quantum physics.
It's simple enough for high school students to grasp
yet so complex that even seasoned
mathematicians haven't mastered it.
This operation is called matrix multiplication.
Matrix multiplication is a very
fundamental operation in
mathematics that appears in many
computations in engineering
and in physics.
A matrix is a two dimensional
array of numbers on which you
can perform operations like
addition and multiplication.
Researchers have long sought
more efficient ways
to multiply matrices together.
So if you even just make that a
little bit faster, larger
problems come into reach.
Where for now, we would say that's too big to
be computable in reasonable time.
However, actually finding faster
matrix multiplication methods is
a huge challenge.
But thanks to a new tool,
researchers have finally broken
a long standing matrix multiplication record,
one that's more than 50 years old.
What's their secret weapon?
Students of linear algebra are
taught a method for multiplying
matrices based on a centuries
old algorithm.
It goes like this.
Multiply elements from the
first row of matrix A
and the first column of matrix B
and add them to get the first element of matrix C.
Then repeat for the first row of matrix A
and the second column of matrix B, and
add them for the second element in matrix C.
And so on.
Multiplying two two
by two matrices this way,
takes eight multiplication steps.
Multiplying any two N by N matrices with the standard
algorithm takes N-cubed steps.
Which is why applying this
method to pairs of larger
matrices quickly becomes
unwieldy.
If you take a matrix that is
twice as big, then you have to
have a computation time that is
eight times more.
So you can imagine, if you doubled it a
couple of times, then you take
eight times more a couple of
times, and you will very soon
reach the limits of what a
computer can do.
Enter Volker Strassen,
a German mathematician known for his
work analyzing algorithms.
In 1969, he discovered a new algorithm to multiply two by two matrices
that requires only seven multiplication steps.
Going from eight down to seven multiplications
may seem trivial,
and the new addition steps look more complicated.
But Strassen's algorithm offers dramatic
computational savings for larger matrices.
That's because when multiplying large
matrices, they can be broken down into smaller ones.
For example, an eight by eight
matrix can reduce to a series of
nested two by two matrices.
So Strassen's savings applied to these smaller matrix
multiplications propagate over and over.
Applying Strassen's to an eight by eight matrix results
in a third fewer multiplication
steps compared to the standard  algorithm.
For very large matrices, these savings vastly
outweigh the computation costs of the extra additions.
A year after Strassen invented his algorithm,
IBM researcher Shmuel Winograd
proved it was impossible to use six or fewer multiplications
to multiply two by two matrices,
thus also proving that Strassens, with its
seven multiplications is the best solution.
For half a century the most
efficient method known for
multiplying two matrices of any
reasonable size was to break
them down and apply Strassen's algorithm.
That was until October 2022, a new algorithm
was revealed that beat
Strassen's, specifically for multiplying two four by four  matrices
where the elements are
only zero or one.
This new algorithm made it possible to
multiply large matrices even faster
by breaking them into four by four matrices
instead of two by two's.
So who or what was behind This
breakthrough?
This new algorithm was
discovered by Google's
artificial intelligence research
lab, DeepMind.
For more than a decade, DeepMind has garnered
attention for training AI systems
to master a host of games, everything from Atari Pong to chess.
Then, in 2016, DeepMind's AlphaGo achieved
what was considered impossible at the time,
it defeated the top ranked human Go player, Lee Sedol , in
a best of five match.
This victory shattered the limited notion of what's possible for computers to achieve.
DeepMind then set its sights on a problem even more challenging than Go.
I was like very surprised that
even for very small cases, we
don't even know what's the optimal
way of doing matrix multiplication.
And at some point, we realized
that this is actually a very good fit for machine learning techniques
To tackle matrix multiplication.
DeepMind started with an
algorithm descended from AlphaGo
called AlphaTensor.
AlphaTensor is built on a
reinforcement learning algorithm
called AlphaZero.
So what one needs to do is to go really beyond the AlphaZero
reinforcement learning algorithm
and to tackle this huge search
space and to develop techniques
to find this, these needles in a
very, very large haystack.
AlphaTensor isn't the first
computer program to assist with
mathematical research.
In 1976, two mathematicians proved what's called the Four Color Theorem using a computer.
The theorem states, you only need four
colors to fill in any map so no
neighboring regions match.
The pair verified their proof by processing all 1936 required
cases
requiring more than 1000  hours of computing time.
Back then the larger mathematical community
was not prepared to cede logical reasoning to a machine.
However, the field has since come a long way.
AlphaTensor was trained with a technique called
reinforcement learning, which is kind of like
playing a game.
Reinforcement Learning strategically penalizes
and rewards an AI system as it
experiments with different ways
to achieve its given task,
driving the program towards an
optimal solution.
But what kind of game should AlphaTensor play
in search of more efficient
matrix multiplication algorithms?
This is where the term tensor in
AlphaTensor comes into play.
A tensor is just an array of
numbers with any number of  dimensions.
Vectors are 1D tensors, and matrices are 2D tensors.
The process of multiplying any two matrices of a given size
can be described by a single unique 3D tensor.
For example, when multiplying any two, two by two matrices,
we can build the corresponding 3D tensor.
Each dimension of this cube represents one of the matrices,
each element in the cube can be one zero or negative one.
The matrix product C is created by combining elements
from matrices A and B, like this.
And so on.
Until you have the full matrix
multiplication tensor.
Now, you can use a process
called tensor decomposition to
break down this 3D tensor into
building blocks.
Similar to taking apart a cube puzzle.
One natural way to break tensors down is into what's called
rank-1 tensors,
which are just products of vectors.
The trick is each rank-1 tensor here describes a multiplication step
in a matrix multiplication algorithm.
For example, this rank-1 tensor represents the
first multiplication step in the
standard algorithm: A1 times B1.
The next rank-1 tensor
represents A2 times B3.
Adding these two rank one tensors
yields the first element in the product C1.
Here are the next two rank-1
tensors, representing the
multiplications, A1 times B2 and
A2 times B4, which form C2.
Eventually, the entire standard
algorithm with its eight
multiplication steps is
represented by decomposing the
3D tensor into eight rank-1 tensors.
These all add back up into the original 3D tensor.
But it's possible to decompose a
3D tensor in different ways.
Strassen's seven multiplication
steps for the same two by two
matrix multiplication looks like this.
These rank-1 tensors are more complex.
And this is still a full decomposition, but in fewer steps,
which add backup to the original tensor.
So the fewer rank-1 tensors, you use to
fully decompose a 3D tensor,
the fewer multiplication steps used
in the tensor's corresponding matrix multiplication.
DeepMind's construction of a
single-player game
for  AlphaTensor to play, and learn
from was key.
Find an algorithm for this matrix multiplication
that requires the fewest
multiplication steps possible...
is a vague request.
But it becomes a clearly defined
computer task
once it's formulated as: decompose this 3D tensor
using as few unique rank-1 tensors as possible,
It's really hard to describe what, what the search space looks like.
In the particular
case of matrix multiplication,
that's, that's quite, it's quite convenient to formulate it in that space,
because then we can
deploy our search techniques
and our machine learning techniques
in order to search in that very,
very large, but formalizable
search spaces.
AlphaTensor's play was simple.
It was programmed to guess rank-1 tensors to subtract from
the original 3D tensor,
to  decompose it down to zero.
The fewer rank one tensors it used,
the more rewards that got.
Each rank-1 tensor that you
remove from from the 3D tensor,
is has a cost, has a cost of let's say one.
And so we want to figure out what's the way of
achieving the goal with the fewest penalties.
And so that's what the system is trying to learn how to do
it's learning to estimate, well when I'm in this kind of configuration,
roughly how many penalties do I think I'm going to incur
before I get to the goal?
But tensor decomposition is not
an easy game to master.
For even a three by three matrix multiplication
with only elements zero or one,
the number of possible tensor decompositions
exceeds the number of atoms in the universe.
Still, over the course of its
training,
AlphaTensor started to home in on patterns to decompose
the tensor efficiently.
Within minutes it rediscovered
Strassen's algorithm.
Then the program went even further.
It beat Strassen's algorithm for
multiplying two, four by four matrices
in modulo-2, where the
elements are only zero or one,
breaking the 50 year record.
Instead of the standard algorithms 64 multiplication steps
or Strassen's 49,
AlphaTensor's algorithm used only 47 multiplications.
AlphaTensor also discovered thousands of other new fast algorithms,
including ones for five by five matrices in modulo-2 .
So, will programs like AlphaTensor,
churning away in server rooms
pulling out new mathematical discoveries from lines of code
make mathematicians obsolete?
Ultimately, I think this will not replace like the
mathematicians or, or anything like that.
This I think provides a good tool that can help
mathematicians find new results
and guide their intuition.
That's exactly what happened just days after the AlphaTensor results
were first published in the journal Nature.
Two mathematicians in Austria, Manuel, Kauers and Jakob Moosbauer
used AlphaTensors 96-step, five by five matrix multiplication algorithm
as inspiration to push even further.
And then Jakob suggested we just take the algorithm
that the AlphaTensor people found
as a starting point and see whether
there's something in the
neighborhood of this, and we
could have an additional drop.
And indeed, that that was the case.
So it was a very short computation for,
for our new mechanism that was able to reduce the 96 to 95.
And this we then published in the arxiv paper.
The right way to look at this
is, as a fantastic example of a
collaboration between a particular kind of technology
and mathematicians.
The true potential for human and
artificial intelligence collaboration
is a frontier that is only now being fully  explored.
I don't think people can be made
irrelevant by any of this kind of work
I think it empowers people to do more.